et c'est là pour dire les choses très
clairement un point désaccord que nous
n'avons pas su résoudre avec les
organisations syndicales réformistes en
particulier nous considérons que le
dispositif que nous proposons permet des
départs anticipés donc une forme de
réparation comme l'utilisation des
points C2P en tenant compte de
l'effectivité de l'exposition à ces
trois critères ergonomiques je prends un
exemple pour illustrer le propos
l'expliquer lorsque nous travaillons sur
des métiers que nous considérons comme
très probablement exposés à cette
pénibilité liée aux trois critères
ergonomiques il y a fort à parier que le
métier de menuisier soit exposé parce
que si vous êtes menuisier sur une
charpente dans des chantiers extérieurs
exposés au froid au chaud et à la
manipulation directe évidemment que le
port de charge les vibrations les
postures pénibles sont au rendez-vous de
ce métier là est nécessite une
réparation autant que nécessaire par
contre si vous êtes menuisier dans un
atelier avec parfois
une température contrôlée et en
utilisant une machine à commande
numérique l'exposition à la pénibilité
aux trois critères est très différente
et pourtant vous avez le même métier
d'un point de vue administratif et donc
le suivi médical renforcé individuel
permet de tenir compte de l'effectivité
le second exemple qui est souvent évoqué
même si ça reste un métier pénible dans
les deux cas à mes yeux concerne les
aides-soignante dans un EHPAD ou tous
les lits sont équipés de rails de
lève-malade n'expose pas la même
pénibilité qu'être exprimant dans un
EHPAD qui dispose pas ses équipements et
donc le suivi médical permet aussi
d'apporter cette réponse différenciée en
fonction de l'effectivité des conditions
de travail